hi everybody it's me pete holmes from
the pete home show and i'm going to be
answering your questions that you sent
to me about thanksgiving and eating food
holiday brought to you by america
my first question comes from sarah
irvine she says what is your favorite
thanksgiving dish what's interesting
sarah if i'm here in la with my groovy
hippie friends i'll tell them the truth
which is i really like a refreshing
dairy-free kale caesar
that's true but if i'm at home see what
i am is a fleegan it's a word i made up
which means flexible vegan and the
flexible part comes in things like
thanksgiving my mom offers me something
that's not vegan i'll just eat it
because it's easier to do that than have
a two hour conversation about how darry
makes me logie
dee buckley says would you rather sit at
the adult table or the kids table i
gotta say kids table all the way d
that's where the fun is you can throw
food make a mess sing songs that don't
even exist just for fun
you don't have to tiptoe around your
aunt steph and uncle ted who are
apparently having problems again
yikes
someone want to carve the tension
david toby yes wants to know what are
some of the things your family members
do year after year that really make
thanksgiving dot dot dot uh dot dot dot
a special time well david i'd like to
thank you for the creepiest use of an
ellipses and a one dot too many ellipses
that i've ever seen uh it's really kind
of suggestive i don't know what you're
getting at my family doesn't do anything
weird or atypical on thanksgiving it's
totally normal just a group of mature
rational adults who eat bread crumbs out
of a turkey's butt
because we're american
steve bravati says if you could combine
two holidays together which two would
you choose i'd like to combine arbor day
and halloween so kids in the
neighborhood could dress up they'd come
to my house and i'd give them a treat
shitty houses give out shrubs
i'd also like to combine christmas and
april fool's day so we tell the kids
that santa's there and all the presents
are under the tree for them they're all
these toys and then they open them up
and it's just filled with homework
you kids
[__] you
i'm gonna be a bad father
thank you so much everybody for your
wonderful thanksgiving questions i hope
you have a great holiday uh i want to
make a person will be like pass the
potatoes but i'm not there but have fun
like i were there
i love you